[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au programme de l'actualité des
infos pratiques et des idées de sortie
bonsoir Nicolas dandry bien installé
pour la prochaine demi-heure on a
beaucoup de sujets abordés et on va voir
tout de suite le programme de ce jeudi 3
novembre
l'autorisation a été donnée début
octobre à partir du 13 novembre Parly 2
pourra ouvrir tous les dimanches comme
d'autres centres commerciaux des
Yvelines qu'est-ce que cela change
concrètement pour l'établissement situé
au généraux concours polynarion
directrice de Westfield Parly 2 et notre
invité à la recherche de nouveaux
talents Poissy Poissy invite des jeunes
passionnés par le chant la composition
l'écriture ou la pratique d'un
instrument à se faire connaître de
nouvelles sessions d'enregistrement sont
prévues au sein des studios de la source
on en parle avec Audrey le père et lui
délégué la Jeunesse et à la vie
étudiante
et puis comme chaque jeudi les idées de
sortie pour le week-end dans les
Yvelines même si les vacances de la
Toussaint s'achève bientôt elles sont
encore nombreuses ses idées notre
sélection à suivre
et vous avez vu notamment à Thoiry avec
la cinquième édition de Thoiry à lumière
sauvage sur place notre journaliste
Gabriel Gontier de la rédaction de TV 78
bonsoir Gabriel
bonsoir Grégory avec un événement qui a
débuté il y a quelques jours donc
oui c'est ça il y a quelques jours le 30
octobre exactement le zoo safari de
Thoiry a ouvert assez visiteurs ces
illuminations comme vous pouvez les voir
derrière moi je suis en compagnie de
Guillaume qui est le directeur
d'exploitation du zoo safari de
thoiriers on y reviendra dans quelques
instants et donc ce sera tout à l'heure
dans cette émission avec moi vous l'avez
vu aussi en début d'édition du 7-8
Nicolas Landry qui vous livrera dans
quelques instants sa sélection des idées
de sortie et avec vous on va jouer aussi
dans cette émission on va découvrir la
culture église comme on le fait chaque
jeudi à travers un quiz et aujourd'hui
on va essayer de deviner et bien les
noms des habitants de certaines communes
yvelinoises donnez-nous aussi l'eau à la
bouche pour les idées de sortie
on peut aller voir des concerts de métal
ce week-end du côté de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux découvrir
peut-être des peintures du côté de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ou encore et
bien allez voir les pistards au
Vélodrome national avec les le Grand
Prix de Vélizy il est resté avec nous
pour connaître la suite bien sûr il faut
rester dans le 7 8 des invités aussi
dans le 7 8 cette émission avec
polynarion qui nous a rejoint également
en plateau bonsoir
directrice directrice de Westfield Parly
2 le centre commercial installé au
Chesnay rock en cours va désormais
ouvrir tous les dimanches et ceux à
partir du 13 novembre l'autorisation a
été donné en octobre comment vous avez
fait pour obtenir cette autorisation
quel était la démarche justement alors
c'est une démarche qui est en cours
depuis plusieurs mois si je veux dire
depuis surtout début de l'année c'est la
constitution d'un dossier on est appuyé
tout simplement par notamment
la mairie de la ville du Séné la CCI de
des Yvelines de Versailles Grand Parc
etc et c'est tout un cheminement
d'attente etc de de consultation de
différentes parties et ensuite
l'autorisation effectivement nous a été
donnée tout début octobre on a été
déclaré en zone commerciale c'est ça qui
nous permet d'ouvrir dorénavant tous les
dimanches donc ça c'est la préfecture
des Yvelines qui octroie cette
autorisation c'est ça et on en dira un
peu plus tout à l'heure à suivre
également un reportage sur le combat
d'habitants de Saint-Hilarion petite
commune des Yvelines contre une antenne
relais mais tout de suite coup d'oeil à
votre météo
[Musique]
ce vendredi il pleut il mouille c'est la
fête non pas à la grenouille mais de
Charles c'est la Saint Charles ce
vendredi à 4 novembre vous le voyez donc
très morose dans les Yvelines avec 8
degrés à Houdan et à Versailles 9 degrés
à Mantes-la-Jolie ce sera plus frais à
Rambouillet avec 7 degrés le matin il
devrait pleuvoir également dans
l'après-midi peut-être avec un ciel plus
clair qui sait compter 12 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 11 degrés à Houdan à
Versailles Rambouillet il fera à 10
degrés la météo de votre weekend dans
les Yvelines à suivre en fin d'émission
quelles sont les informations à retenir
pour cette journée du jeudi à 3 novembre
on fait le point à tout de suite
également sur vos conditions de trafic
en Île-de-France en ce dernier week-end
de la Toussaint et le tout c'est avec
Mélanie pocket
les trottinettes tiers vont prendre
d'assaut un nouveau territoire yvelinois
après 50 ans en Yvelines ou encore la
vallée de Chevreuse c'est la communauté
d'agglomération Grand Paris Senné Oise
qui va les voir s'implanter 12 postes de
facteurs à pourvoir dans les Yvelines la
Poste lance une nouvelle campagne de
recrutement le but faire face au pic
d'activité au moment des fêtes de fin
d'année pour postuler la poste
recrute.fr ce week-end sonne la fin des
vacances scolaires de la Toussaint sur
la route le samedi est classé orange en
région parisienne pour les retours Bison
Futé conseil de rejoindre de traverser
l'île de France avant 14h tous les feux
sont au vert pour prendre la route le
dimanche 6 novembre pas de RER C pour ce
week-end les 5 et 6 novembre la
circulation des trains est interrompue
entre Viroflay rive gauche et
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la SNCF invite
à emprunter la ligne N pour rejoindre
ses gares le FC Versailles 78 va-t-il
continuer sur sa belle lancée vendredi 4
novembre le nouveau promus affronte
Châteauroux pour la 11e journée de
Nationale
club yvelinois est actuellement 3e du
classement Châteauroux et quatrième j-3
avant le départ de la Route du Rhum
parmi les 138 skippers à tenter
l'aventure au solitaire de yvelinois le
rambolitain Louis Burton sur son IMOCA
Bureau Vallée vise un top 5 le
Versailles Bellion prendra le départ de
cette course sur son IMOCA comme un seul
homme power Altavia le départ est donné
le 6 novembre prochain à Saint-Malo et
si vous aussi vous êtes témoin de fait
près de chez vous que vous souhaitez
partager n'hésitez pas à le faire sur
les réseaux en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news dans l'actualité à venir cette
nouveauté du côté de Westfield Parly 2
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure à
partir du 13 novembre le centre
commercial situé au Chesnay Ronc en
cours ouvrira tous les dimanches
polynario est avec nous en plateau pour
en parler vous êtes je le rappelle la
directrice de Westfield Parly 2 pourquoi
c'était nécessaire de faire cette
démarche justement de vouloir ouvrir les
dimanches
alors pour différentes raisons la
première c'est tout simplement de
répondre aux besoins de la clientèle qui
aujourd'hui est désireuse de venir dans
un centre de shopping déjà pour faire du
shopping mais pas que pour se balader
pour profiter d'un endroit où on peut
représenter un la culture d'un endroit
aussi où on représente des loisirs on
propose différents loisirs à nos
visiteurs et autre chose également pour
répondre aux besoins des commerçants
on était les seuls acteurs de la zone
presque de l'Île-de-France pas tout à
fait mais quasiment ne pas être ouvert
le dimanche donc voilà aujourd'hui il y
avait aucune raison pour qu'on reste
fermé et on est vraiment ravis ravi de
pouvoir enfin ouvrir tous les dimanches
à partir du dimanche 13 novembre
commerciaux d'autres commerces dans les
Yvelines sont ouverts également le
dimanche c'était une sorte de
concurrence déloyale pour vous non c'est
pas une sorte de concurrence de loi et
je pense qu'on est tous complémentaires
c'est juste historiquement par ligne
n'était pas ouverte et tout simplement
on a constitué un dossier pour qu'on le
soit dorénavant et vous avez dit que ça
venait des commerçants c'est
c'est de eux que vient cette demande
finalement ils étaient vraiment
demandeurs d'ouvrir le dimanche alors
oui tout à fait ça vient de mais pas
uniquement évidemment et puis par nous
on n'aurait jamais constitué un dossier
d'ouverture des dimanches si nos
commerçants n'avaient pas été d'accord
c'est impossible on doit être suivi par
nos commerçants pour ce type de démarche
déjà puisque ça remet aussi leur rythme
enfin voilà en question ils vont
dorénavant ouvrir tous les dimanches ils
sont très contents puisque on va pouvoir
enfin travailler mais comme nos
concurrents même si j'aime pas trop ce
terme là mais de la même façon et puis
au-delà de ça c'est un souci de
recrutement également aujourd'hui on
pouvait avoir quelques petits sujets de
recrutement puisque les employés
souhaitent pour certains travails
dimanche et on n'avait pas cette
possibilité notamment des étudiants par
exemple tout à fait étudiants c'est très
très recherché d'ailleurs on a fait un
job dating il y a quelques jours et ça a
été un grand succès comme ça comment ça
se prépare concrètement de passer de six
jours sur 7 à 7 jours sur 7 comment ça
se prépare alors ce que ça change les
choses oui bien sûr ça change le
quotidien ça change l'organisation le
dimanche le centre est fermé les
lumières sont éteintes il n'y a pas de
commerçant les parkings sont fermés donc
d'un point de vue logistique ça change
énormément d'un point de vue budgétaire
aussi c'est des voilà des
on retravaille en fait tout simplement
pour pouvoir
gérer les choses correctement puis
au-delà de ça c'est aussi en terme de
communication pour informer nos
visiteurs que dorénavant on sera ouvert
les dimanches donc c'est la mise en
place d'un grand plan de communication
qui va commencer tout début de semaine
prochaine Nicolas une question peut-être
vous faites le choix d'ouvrir tous les
dimanches à partir du mois de novembre
il y a aussi une stratégie par rapport à
au fait je suppose parce que là c'est
une grosse période une part importante
peut-être de votre du chiffre d'affaires
de vos commerçants alors oui bien sûr
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que déjà
les années précédentes aussi Parly 2
était ouverte à partir de la mi-novembre
on va dire jusqu'à la fin décembre pour
les fêtes de fin d'année nous le choix
qu'on a fait c'est tout simplement
d'attendre ce moment pour ensuite
continuer l'ouverture des dimanches je
vais être pour déjà que ce soit plus
simple pour les pour les visiteurs qui
comprennent ou qu'on est ouvert et qu'on
fasse pas sans trouver en fait de fin
d'année fermée pendant 15 jours par
exemple
errer ouvert au vu de la conjoncture
actuelle comment vos commerçants qui
sont situés dans votre centre
se sente par rapport à au fait est-ce
que il semble que ça va être une bonne
période pour eux alors oui déjà les
commerciaux sont toujours très contents
d'arriver au fait de fin d'année de un
voilà pour le chiffre d'affaires le
nombre de visiteurs mais pas que c'est
vraiment une ambiance dans les centres
qui est assez extraordinaire je vous
invite vraiment à venir découvrir les
décorations de Noël seront en place des
signes d'ici quelques jours maintenant
forcément les les commerçants sont très
positifs et pour la mise en place des
fêtes de fin d'année et puis pour
l'ouverture du dimanche et ça fait ça
fait plaisir de les entendre de les
entendre positivement et on imagine
aussi bien après deux années marquées
par par le covid d'ailleurs le centre
commercial Parly 2 avait ouvert l'an
passé sur une période courte de mai à
juillet les dimanches est-ce que vous en
avez retiré une bonne expérience
croyances justement de cette courte
période justement qui a été faite pour
rattraper les mois d'inactivité du haut
covid oui tout à fait en fait on a eu
l'autorisation d'un point de vue
municipal et puis même préfectoral
d'ouvrir
tout simplement sur des personnes qui à
la base n'était pas autorisées
évidemment que c'est toujours très
positif de toute façon plus on peut la
trouver plus on est content forcément
puisque plus on a de visiteurs et puis
plus on peut répondre tout simplement
aux besoins de nos consommateurs de nos
visiteurs de nos clients donc oui c'est
toujours toujours positif quels seront
les horaires d'ouverture le dimanche
alors à bien noté il y a deux choses
différentes là pour jusqu'à la fin
d'année donc du dimanche 13 novembre au
dernier dimanche de décembre qui sera le
25 décembre on sera fermé le 25 décembre
néanmoins donc on sera ouvert jusqu'au
dimanche d'avant les horaires sont 10
heures 19h30 mais par contre à partir du
mois de janvier on a souhaité dans un
premier temps raccourcir un petit peu
ses horaires ce sera du 11 heures 19
heures donc dans un premier temps 10h
19h30 et puis à partir de 2023 11h 19h
et donc première ouverture le dimanche
le 13 novembre tout est prêt tout est
prêt
merci d'être venu en parler sur ce
plateau polynario et je rappelle que
vous êtes la directrice du centre
commercial ouest-field Parly 2 direction
Saint-Hilarion à présent avec le combat
d'un collectif d'habitants cela fait
suite à l'installation en mai dernier et
d'un pylône téléphonique à 300 mètres
seulement des habitations l'opérateur
Orange devait s'y installer mais c'est
finalement rétracter les membres du
collectif dénoncent un projet
inutile et néfaste on regarde tout de
suite ce reportage de Julien Leroy
partout je me déplace j'ai vu direct sur
l'antenne
alors que ce soit à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur dans la petite ville de
Saint-Hilarion certains habitants du
lieu-dit Le Fléau ne décolèrent pas en
cause l'installation d'un pylône
téléphonique de 30 mètres de haut par
l'opérateur d'infrastructures TDF en mai
dernier un collectif composé de 19
foyers dénonces une implantation sans
réelle utilité à 300 mètres de leur
domicile il y a pas de projet quoi c'est
le problème ce qu'aujourd'hui la mairie
n'a pas dit bah tiens il y a un besoin
SFR Bouygues de s'installer il y a
possiblement des voilà des problèmes de
couverture en bas du village mais rien
ne dit que le pullone comme il est
installéa va permettre de répondre à ce
besoin de de réseau mobile en bas du
village qui nous soucie dans tout ça
c'est que bah la mairie n'a pas du tout
communiqué sur sur ce projet donc ça a
traité ça comme une déclaration
d'urbanisme comme une autre de son côté
le maire admet un manque de
communication mais se défend en
affirmant que TDF a construit le pylône
sur un terrain privé ces actions pour
l'interdire étaient donc
de signer ce permis de construire car il
n'y avait aucun obstacle légal pour que
nous l'interdions qu'il y a d'un côté
des gens qui demandent à avoir du chant
sur leur téléphone et de l'autre qui ne
veulent pas d'un pilon bricher voilà le
maire est toujours obligé d'arbitrer
entre deux mécontentements cet habitant
affirme que sa maison a perdu 10% de sa
valeur suite à l'installation du pylône
elle a mis en vente son bien par crainte
des dangers potentiels de l'antenne sur
la santé humaine je m'en vais parce que
personne peut nous dire si les ondes
sont néfastes ou pas moi j'en suis sûr
donc pour moi enfin pour ma famille pour
mes petits-enfants les membres de 0 g en
action ont déposé un recours contentieux
devant le tribunal administratif de
Versailles les projets d'installation
d'opérateurs mobiles sur ce pylône sont
donc pour le moment gelés le collectif
espère que le préjudice esthétique
permettra de faire démonter la structure
pour sa part la société TDF affirme que
cette installation a été faite dans les
règles
et on ouvre à présent une page culture
dans le 7 8
[Musique]
avec une nouvelle invité en plateau
Audrey Lepère bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes concernés municipal de la
ville de Poissy délégué à la Jeunesse et
à la vie étudiante alors on vous reçoit
pour parler de ce cet appel lancé par la
ville de Poissy à tous les jeunes d'au
moins 11 ans qui sont passionnés par la
musique le chant la composition
l'écriture ou la pratique d'un
instrument pour se faire connaître et
pourquoi pour organiser la ville
organise avec ces jeunes de nouvelles
sessions d'enregistrement qui sont
prévues à la source qui est l'espace
jeunesse de la ville pourquoi rechercher
de nouveaux talents pourquoi rechercher
ses talents musicaux ces jeunes talents
musicaux
donc pour juin 2023 pour la prochaine
session de la jeunesse en fait pourquoi
parce qu'il y ait des pépites sur 38
habitants à Poissy il y a des pépites il
y a une belle mixité on a au moins 10
quartiers l'objectif de ce projet c'est
tout d'abord faire une vraie audition
dans laquelle effectivement on est dans
cette première étape dans laquelle on
peut aussi faire en vie plus jeune dans
quelque part ils ont été exprimer post
covid ils ont une forme de frustration
et je pense que dans la période de
l'adolescence c'est une paire dans
laquelle on a envie de s'exprimer il y a
aussi beaucoup de paradoxes et pourquoi
aussi tout simplement parce qu'on a
envie de s'exprimer alors quotidien ce
qui rencontre vraiment dans leur vie ce
qui découvre donc cette première étape
audition est importante et ensuite on
aura une seconde étape qui sera
effectivement les enregistrements qui
sera effectivement au mois de décembre
mais aujourd'hui voilà je j'invite à
tous les jeunes picia kays à partir de
11 ans devenir à la source qui est du
guichet unique de la jeunesse de Poissy
dans lequel il y a un studio il y a du
matériel de haut niveau dans lequel
effectivement des jeunes sont déjà venus
faire des des premières auditions tout
simplement en octobre il y avait
beaucoup de monde comment on a répondu
présent on est venu alors il y a aussi
une session on est venu vraiment dans le
quartier rencontrer les maisons de
quartier un peu pour interroger sur ce
qu'ils avaient envie de faire alors
effectivement il y a du rap il y a du
slam il y a aussi des gens qui des
jeunes qui font du classique c'est tout
type de musique voilà c'est vrai que
l'envie c'est vrai que c'est un projet
que j'avais envie de faire depuis avant
la covid de pouvoir un petit peu
connaître un peu les tendances parce que
ça bouge énormément on les voit même sur
les réseaux sociaux
s'exprimer c'est bien mais aussi de voir
des nouvelles des nouvelles compétences
appétence aussi sur le monde musical ça
bouge très très vite et je j'avais très
envie de découvrir un petit peu ce qui
avait ce qu'il y avait au fond du ventre
c'est ces jeunes là ce qui a envie de
découvrir et nous on a déjà commencé à
faire deux sessions de auditions donc ça
très bien marché faut savoir aussi que
cette ce projet c'est un projet
collaboratif avec Arnaud beksoulet
issu du milieu du rap c'est a ouvert à
d'autres d'autres styles mais qui vous
accompagnent ça a été facile de le
convaincre totalement il est venu tout
d'abord rencontrer Monsieur carloli qui
est le député de la douzième
circonscription et quand on a commencé à
se rencontrer c'était évident il a
vraiment des belles valeurs à donner il
y a des vraies compétences artistiques
et aussi il est capable de pouvoir aussi
accompagner ces jeunes là donc quand ce
projet là c'est mené c'était totalement
évident
faut savoir aussi que l'ambition c'est
de faire un album mais c'est une
première étape c'est un nouveau projet
donc il faut effectivement instaurer
communiquer parler un petit peu de ce
qui se passe pose cogite donc les
échanges sont très faciles sont super
agréables donc tout d'abord c'est
important de rappeler que la jeunesse
commence à partir de l'âge de 11 ans et
on se dit elles peuvent à peu près 30
ans maximum sur la tranche d'âge les
jeunes étudiants parce qu'il y a ça
aussi donc c'est avec juste trois
nouvelles sessions je le rappelle juste
ce sera donc le 9 novembre à 18h 19
novembre à 16h et 26 novembre à 18h
c'est bien ça voilà j'ai noté j'ai noté
ces dates du coup comment ça se passe
concrètement ils prennent contact avec
le service jeunesse il y a une audition
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
beaucoup de d'échanges sur le terrain
énormément on a effectivement sa liste
de communication avec des flyers où on
film on rencontre les différents
commerçants échanger oui j'ai un jeune
qui aimerait faire la musique et aussi
sur une partie très on a à Poissy un
magazine qui s'appelle # Poissy dans
lequel effectivement on fait beaucoup de
communications sur ces dates le 9
novembre le 16 et le 26 novembre donc
des étapes importantes après
effectivement on est toujours assez
ouvert on parle d'audition mais c'est
plutôt aussi une rencontre exactement
l'idée c'est effectivement de pouvoir
créer de fédérer aussi des valeurs c'est
surtout notion là qui moi qui
m'intéresse notamment après donc vers
cet enregistrement d'album c'est ça il y
a vraiment un bel accompagnement je suis
assez contente d'ailleurs de ce projet
là qui est très soutenu par carloli et
également par notre nouvelle mère Madame
le Maire Sandrine qui vraiment très ravi
de ce projet là donc c'est très très
important aussi de valoriser l'artiste
aussi l'artistique musical c'est comme
ça qu'on peut les rencontrer et les
faire découvrir parce que c'est un album
et qui va aussi être distribué donc
auprès des des artistes qui sont
extrêmement connus donc voilà Arnaud des
school connaît beaucoup de personnalités
donc c'est aussi un moyen pour avoir une
espèce le tremplin aussi derrière les
accompagner on sait dans un milieu
musical qui est très compliqué c'est
aussi pour pas qu'il se perde c'est
aussi ça l'idée c'est une très bonne
question oui effectivement moi je trouve
que c'est important de pouvoir
accompagner de effectivement aussi
d'avoir une forme d'éducation derrière
d'avoir une structure un cas c'est la
source le guichet unique de la jeunesse
de Poissy qu'ils accompagnent qui les
orientent il y a une forme aussi
d'échange de valeur aussi de
construction de de la personnalité on a
suivi des jeunes de l'âge de 11 ans
maintenant ils ont 15 ans on les voit
grandir on les voit se se construire et
devenir des jeunes très jeunes adultes
mais en tout cas c'est toujours
valorisant de dire voilà ce petit jeune
il vient de de Poissy voilà ce qui
devient aussi une forme de ouais de
d'exemplarité dans ces parcours
peut-être une dernière question je sais
pas Nicolas un mot sur c'est de la
période vous l'avez dit vous avez
réfléchi à ce projet avant la covid
finalement il y a eu la crise sanitaire
c'est vrai que ça ça a perturbé le lien
social entre les habitants je suppose
que un projet comme tel ça favorise
justement la rencontre entre les
habitants le lien social si c'est après
cette crise sanitaire vous avez tout à
fait raison c'est vrai que le fait de
pouvoir créer en tout cas d'instaurer
post covid ce type de projet c'est
extrêmement valorisant puis c'est
surtout aussi pour les jeunes comme vous
le dites de pouvoir renouer des contacts
on va dire en tant que présentiel et
pouvoir aussi favoriser la communication
l'expression aussi orale qui est
extrêmement crucial on parle beaucoup
des réseaux sociaux mais le fait de
pouvoir s'exprimer devant un groupe
quand on a 11 ans on a fait dernièrement
une audition un jeune de 11 ans c'est
c'est présenté à slamer face à des
jeunes adultes il a dit des choses très
intéressantes sans pour autant parler de
vulgarité il était très
important dans quand on parle de ce qui
de ce qui rencontre dans son quotidien
ça a été extrêmement formateur c'est
vraiment intéressant de pouvoir
retrouver effectivement ces échanges
entre entre les jeunes tout à fait très
rapidement Audrey Lepère vous avez déjà
détecté quelques pépites oui bien sûr on
verra par la suite vous n'en dites pas
plus et on verra par la suite donc pour
ce projet d'albums qui arrivera et pour
contacter avoir toutes les informations
peut-être vous inscrire aussi et prendre
contact avec la ville de Poissy
n'hésitez pas à écrire un mail à
l'adresse qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci Audrey Lepère d'être venu
en parler en plateau conseillère
municipal de la ville de Poissy on parle
à présent d'une exposition 50
photographies pour 50 ans de carrière le
Château de Rambouillet est expos
jusqu'au 9 janvier les clichés de
l'artiste britannique Michael Kenna des
prises de vue en noir et blanc autour
d'un thème celui du patrimoine le
reportage de Mélanie poquet
quelques minutes ou plusieurs heures à
patienter pour un cliché Michael qui n'a
peut installer son appareil toute une
nuit pour une photographie un travail un
regard qu'il pose en voyageant sur le
patrimoine
[Musique]
c'est un goût de l'enfance il a toujours
aimé les paysages donc pour lui c'est
son univers personnel c'est un il se
définit lui-même comme un romantique
donc il aime décrire les sentiments et à
travers le paysage il exprime
ses sentiments
[Musique]
un travail en noir et blanc pour créer
un univers particulier 50 clichés sont
actuellement exposés au Château de
Rambouillet 50 clichés pour 50 ans de
carrière tirées d'une carte blanche
commandée par les centres des monuments
nationaux souvent on pense photo
documentaire qui permettent de faire la
promotion touristique de nos monuments
donc on a cette mission on a beaucoup de
photographes qui font cela mais parfois
on fait un petit pas de côté et on se
dit il faut aussi confier à des artistes
le soin de porter un autre regard
[Musique]
du Château de Rambouillet à celui de
Versailles en passant par
Vaux-le-Vicomte ou encore le Désert de
Retz Michael Kena partage son amour du
patrimoine des Yvelines et d'ailleurs
[Musique]
et d'autres idées de sortie à présent
direction Thoiry avec la cinquième
édition de Thoiry lumière sauvage on
vous en parlait au début du 7 8 la
féerie et ton rendez-vous pour le zoparc
et sur place on retrouve tout de suite
Gabriel Gontier rebonsoir et je disais
tout à l'heure Gabriel le rendez-vous a
débuté depuis quelques jours et depuis
le 30 octobre
exactement Grégory depuis le 30 octobre
et justement je suis avec Guillaume
chiffreau qui est le directeur
d'exploitation du zoo safari de Thoiry
pour nous parler de cet événement alors
déjà est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce qu'on peut voir derrière
nous et comment vous avez organisé cette
année les expositions
de Thoiry de plus de 2000 lanternes et
c'est un travail qui pour nous comme en
France au mois de juin avec la
préparation la rénovation des lanternes
nos ateliers et puis on reçoit à partir
de fin août des nouvelles lanternes et
on installe tout ça pour que être prêt
pour ouvrir fin octobre et alors
justement c'est la cinquième édition
comment vous faites pour vous renouveler
tous les ans pour trouver des nouvelles
idées alors en fait les scènes changent
on est dans une zone marine l'année
dernière c'était un thème totalement
différent on réutilise chaque année des
lanternes voilà on va dire en recycle
volontaire et on recrée des nouvelles
scénographies à chaque fois et puis on a
des pièces majeures qui peuvent venir
d'une année sur l'autre là on le voit
peut-être il y a des requins énormes
donc ça fait partie des effets un peu
waouh chaque année et alors il y a une
partie de la confection de ces lanternes
qui se fait en Chine par des ouvriers
chinois comment comment ça se passe des
artistes même plutôt je pense exactement
c'est un archi noir en fait qui vient de
la région du Sichuan c'est les lanternes
traditionnels il nous sur la base de
dessin et de croquis que nous faisons
ici à Thoiry par nos équipes internes il
réalise les lanternes et après nous sont
transmises via bateau ici et après
n'oubliez pas de lanterne aussi qu'on a
appris maintenant à rénover il y a
quelques années les artistes venaient
ici ils ont pu transmettre un peu leur
savoir à nos équipes et du coup
maintenant c'est un travail en
partenariat entre eux et nous alors
Thoiry lumière sauvage c'est maintenant
un incontournable pardon du zoo
qu'est-ce qui fait que ça marche aussi
bien année après année c'est devenu un
vrai rendez-vous je pense que ce qui
marche bien c'est que le bel effet qu'on
se renouvelle on a des gens qui viennent
chaque année à chaque fois c'est
différent on en prend plein les yeux
même nous les équipes c'est toujours une
surprise au premier allumage fin octobre
donc je pense que c'est ce qui plaît
beaucoup et puis c'est un moment qui est
assez magique qui dure pendant plusieurs
mois puisqu'on commence le 30 octobre et
cette année on va finir le 5 mars et
donc vous pouvez venir à différents
moments de l'année au moment des fêtes
on a beaucoup de familles qui viennent
pour voir cette festival là aussi alors
là justement on est dans la période de
vacances scolaires vous avez eu déjà de
nombreuses visiteurs qui sont venus
notre plus grosse ouverture sur les 5
ans voilà on a eu plus de 7000 personnes
le premier dimanche d'ouverture ce qui
pour nous un record donc on est on est
très exposés c'est important pour les
équipes de voir que leur travail de
plusieurs mois soit apprécié et là on
l'a vu pendant toutes les vacances il y
a beaucoup de monde donc ça c'est
vraiment plaisant pour nous c'est à dire
que encore une fois on a réussi notre
pari alors cette année avec les
conditions qu'on connaît la sobriété
énergétique les restrictions est-ce que
un moment ça a été remis en cause ces
illuminations comment vous êtes adapté
alors remis en cause non c'est quand
même bien posé les questions encore une
fois c'est comme tout à chacun l'énergie
c'est aussi important dans les budgets
d'un parc animalier mais depuis
plusieurs années en fait le zoo est dans
une démarche de protection de la nature
de d'économie de ressources donc voilà
donc c'est des gestes quotidien sur est
un des lumières dans les toilettes
présences et nous sur le festival cette
année on consomme 20% de moins que les
années précédentes principalement dû au
fait qu'on a réduit nos horaires de
d'allumage et lanterne et puis 100% de
lanterne et des différentes guirlandes
sont en ligne merci beaucoup Guillaume
tiffraud je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur d'exploitation aux eaux safari
de Thoiry et que ces illuminations sont
à découvrir jusqu'au 5 mars et Merci à
VOUS Gabriel Gontier aussi à Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude qui était présent sur
place au moyen technique Nicolas Landry
vous souhaitiez réagir oui oui juste
prévenir l'attention derrière vous avez
une tortue genre je sais pas ce qu'elle
va faire mais attention à vous quand
même
effectivement on va continuer d'aller
découvrir tout ça merci Gabriel alors
c'est une bonne idée de sortie alors
bientôt malheureusement c'est la fin des
vacances de la Toussaint vous allez nous
consoler Nicolas dandry Gabriel l'a déjà
fait un petit peu et vous allez nous
livrer votre sélection à des idées de
sortie à faire ce weekend dans les
Yvelines et qui a été aussi préparé je
le précise avec le concours de Régine
ralech et de Julien Leroy on débute en
musique oui effectivement pour les
amateurs de 12 mélodies et bien j'ai une
bonne idée la onzième édition de metal
sphère revient à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
un rendez-vous qui met donc la musique
métal à l'honneur en conviant des
artistes locaux mais aussi d'envergure
national des groupes tels que resolve
ndkh ou encore solitaris seront au
programme de ce festival alors après si
vous préférez quelque chose de plus
calme il y a la musée de la le musée de
la batellerie et des voies navigables de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine qui vous
propose une exposition de peinture huile
aquarelle gravure et dessin mettant en
avant les paysages et les filières
batelières Conflanais proposer à travers
des peintres tels que Albert Marquet
Jean de La Motte ou encore André Langlet
bon halloween c'est comme les vacances
de la Toussain c'est terminé vous aviez
choisi quel costumes cette année Nicolas
classique Frankenstein voilà alors c'est
terminé Halloween mais l'ambiance
d'Halloween continue encore quelques
jours à France Miniature oui du côté des
lampes en cours elle conserve son
ambiance effrayante des squelettes ont
envahi les célèbres monuments au
programme jeux de piste distribution de
bonbons et autres surprises alors
dépêchez-vous d'en profiter une dernière
fois ce week-end avant la fermeture
hivernale ce dimanche 6 novembre alors
après les bonbons on peut faire aussi un
peu de sport ce weekend alors si vous
souhaitez ressentir de vivre émotions et
je sais que vous aimez ça Grégory et
bien direction le vélodrome national
avec le 8e Grand Prix de Vélizy dimanche
6 novembre plusieurs champions
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
s'affronteront au programme course
d'endurance et de vitesse réalisée par
une centaine de coureurs on termine avec
un spectacle d'humour l'une de vos
nombreux spécialités Nicolas Grégory
pour merci une période difficile en
amour ce n'est pas mon cas vous pourrez
trouver un peu de réconfort devant le
spectacle cocu de Kevin Levy à la Royal
Factory de Versailles l'humoriste
raconte le moment où il apprend à avoir
été cocu après 9 ans de relation entre
sketch musique et danse le spectacle de
fait Kevin Lévy vous fera sécher vos
larmes on regarde un extrait
tout le temps
merci pour cette sélection Nicolas et
c'est le moment tant attendu dans cette
émission ces nouveautés dans le 7 8 on
l'avait expérimenté la semaine dernière
on va jouer avec vous et d'ailleurs nos
invités sont même restés avec nous
Pauline et Audrey Lepère merci d'être
resté et avec vous avec quoi on va jouer
avec le nom des habitants des Yvelines
je crois c'est ça exactement
à travers un petit jeu entre nous avec
nos invités vous pouvez aussi jouer sur
les réseaux sociaux vu que vu que qui
nous suivait sur Facebook LinkedIn ou
encore YouTube alors première question
de Grégory monte juste ma feuille aux
invités je n'ai pas les réponses voilà
les réponses je suis le seul à posséder
les réponses et en régie aussi ils ont
les réponses mais alors Grégory je sais
que vous connaissez la réponse à la
première question donc vous pouvez
laisser peut-être nos invités répondre à
cette question comment appelle-t-on les
habitants de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
ce qu'on a droit à un joker
la question s'affiche d'ailleurs à
l'écran vous ne savez pas je ne sais pas
bon Grégory bon vous pouvez donner la
réponse les inondant inhymondins et Igny
Montaine
deuxième question donc dans quelle
commune vivent les carillons et les
carillonnes
Grégory est-ce que vous avez la réponse
les carillons et les carillonnes je
serai plutôt parti pour une un des
carrières non non
ville voisine de Poissy
[Musique]
ou se calme dans une carrière tout
simplement
voilà donc les carillons et les
carillonnes pour les pour les communes
de Carrières-sur-Seine la réponse
s'affiche à l'écran troisième question
comment sont appelés selon vous les
habitants de Saint-Nom-la-Bretèche
alors
non
en fait
quelque chose autour de bretesch
peut-être ça commencerait par un B non
reprennent l'ensemble du nom de la ville
finalement en donnant une saint nommé
breteuchois et les seins naumaises
ah oui c'est ouais il est il est
compliqué celui-là est compliqué
attendez le 4e comment appelle-t-on les
habitants de Toussus-le-Noble alors déjà
est-ce que vous savez ou si tu touches
le nom peut-être dans les Yvelines
non je ne sais pas
à la porte de du territoire et Sonia
juste après 50 ans en Yvelines avec un
aérone sur le terrain
connue pour son aérodrome alors selon
vous comment s'appelle les habitants de
cette ville
non vous avez pas d'idée Grégory
peut-être autour de noble les Nords les
nobles il suffit de prendre le tissu le
le terme du prix le prix Nobel et vous
mettez une belle tussois les nouvelles
tu soignes voilà donc
très jolie désolé
dernière question dernière commune
comment sont appelés les habitants de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines ça je sais
55 ans
il va falloir je pense qu'il va falloir
intégrer des bonus dans dans ce quiz
Grégory
pour les invités
alors un petit indice vous vous prenez
juste le terme
Yvelines vous prenez juste le terme
Arnaud et vous pouvez constituer du coup
le nom des habitants de cette commune
soit c'est peut-être un peu trop
compliqué juste
non vous séchez aussi bon les
arnolitains
si on peut afficher la réponse donc ce
sont les arnoldiens
alors j'espère que vous en avez appris
un peu plus du coup je peux me permettre
de dire les gentils ça s'appelle les
personnes qui habitent dans une ville
c'est une légende de telle ville par
exemple les gens qui les de Poissy ce
sont les pisses
donc les habitants ou les gentilés
courtois pour le chener au concours
parce que le général Rocancourt sont
regroupés depuis quelques années
bon on apprend on en apprend tous les
jours donc tous les jeudis sur la
culture
savoir plus même sur sur la culture et
vinoise merci Nicolas et d'ailleurs vous
pouvez retrouver trois autres questions
surtout Twitter à travers d'autres
communes notamment la commune de
Chambourcy
gamber seul ou encore je sais plus la
dernière mais voilà vous savez c'est les
kangouristes
pour les habitants les gentilés de
Chambourcy Audrey le père et
apollinarium d'avoir été courageuse et
d'être resté avec nous pour jouer autour
du nom des habitants des communes des
Yvelines alors avant de vous laisser on
fait un dernier point sur la météo
et ce vendredi il pleut malheureusement
vous le voyez avec des températures
également très moraux 8 degrés à Houdan
et eversize pour le matin 9 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ce sera plus frais à
Rambouillet avec 7 degrés il devrait
pleuvoir également à l'après-midi
peut-être avec un ciel plus clair
comptez 12 degrés mante la jolie 11
degrés à Houdan à Versailles et
Rambouillet et Rambouillet il fera 10
degrés ce vendredi nous fêterons les
chats est-ce que vous avez des
meilleures nouvelles à nous donner
Nicolas pour la météo du week-end
on va voir pour samedi et bien voilà
notez quelques exercices notamment les
montées vont avoir quelques éclaircies
les houdanés les Versailles ou encore
les rambolitains qui auront des
éclaircies pour le samedi matin comptez
8 degrés pour Versailles Houdan et neuf
degrés pour Mantes-la-Jolie dans
l'après-midi et bien le ciel yvelinois
va se couvrir avec des températures
aussi entre 10 et 11 degrés pour
dimanche et bien c'est la pluie dimanche
matin pluvieux sur le territoire des
Yvelines mais dans l'après-midi il y
aura quelques éclaircies et puis des
températures donc autour pareil de 11 à
10 degrés voilà ça s'améliore dimanche
après-midi pour bien terminer le weekend
et ce sera je le disais tout à l'heure
le dernier weekend des vacances de la
Toussaint avec peut-être quelques
difficultés pour circuler en
Île-de-France sur la route la carte de
Bison Futé des prévisions Bison Futé
s'afficher le samedi est classé orange
en région parisienne pour les retours
Bison Futé conseil de rejoindre ou de
traverser l'Île-de-France avant 14h et
puis tous les feux sont au vert pour
revenir de vacances pour prendre la
route le dimanche 6 novembre et
reprendre le plus reposé possible le
travail le lendemain merci à Nicolas
pour toutes ces précisions et c'est la
fin du 7 8 merci de votre fidélité une
émission bien sûr à retrouver en replay
sur notre site Internet et notre
application mobile TV 78 très belle
soirée à tous et bon weekend par la
suite sur TV 78
[Musique]